♪ ♪
>> Hannity: WELCOME TO
"HANNITY" THE NEW INFLATION
NUMBERS THEY ARE OUT AND THE
NUMBERS ARE A COMPLETE DISASTER
FOR OUR ECONOMY EVEN AS INTEREST
RATES RISE THE ECONOMY IS STILL
CONTRACTING INFLATION IS STILL
HOVERING AT A FOUR DECADE HIGH,
A WHOPPING 8.3% ON A VERY
SERIOUS NOTE THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
IN OUR COUNTRY.
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
IT'S KILLING THE POOR, IT IS
KILLING THE MIDDLE CLASS, IT IS
HURTING PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOMES.
WHILE INCOMES GO DOWN THE STOCK
MARKET IS PLUNGING THAT MEANS
THAT RETIREMENT FUNDS ARE
GETTING DESTROYED, THE COST OF
EVERYTHING THAT YOU BUY IN EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO IS CONTINUING TO
SPIKE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION IS HERE WITH NO END
IN SIGHT SADLY.
GAS PRICES GUESS WHAT?
WE HAD ANOTHER RECORD HIGH
TODAY.
DIESEL TOO ANOTHER RECORD HIGH
AND THEY SOON MAY BE A DIESEL
FUEL SHORTAGE.
UTILITIES IN THIS COUNTRY THERE
UP A WHOPPING 22%.
FUEL OIL IS UP A WHOPPING 80%.
USED CARS ARE ANYWHERE BETWEEN
22, 40%.
THE REP OVER 13% AND BY THE WAY
WHEN YOU FINALLY BUY ONE THE
MSRP STICKER SHOCK IS ABOVE MSRP
IS GONNA BE ABOUT MASSIVE.
LOOKING FOR A PLANE TICKET?
THAT'S UP 33%.
MEAT IS 14%, EX 22%, MILK IS
14%.
ACCORDING TO ECONOMISTS STILL
NEED TO FOLK OVER OVER 5,000,
$200 MORE PER HOUSEHOLD THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN
INFLATION AND OVER $2,000 BY THE
WAY EVERY AMERICAN THAT DRIVES A
CAR THEY WILL PAY AN EXTRA
$2,000 ON GAS PRICES ALONE.
ALREADY AS I SAID TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICANS OF PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK ACCORDING TO CNBC NOW
SADLY ALL OF THIS AS WE BEEN
TELLING YOU COULD BE PREVENTED
MORE THAN A YEAR AGO.
OUR ECONOMY RECOVERED FROM COVID
LOCKDOWNS AND GOT READ IT,
RED-HOT AND PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
JUST CONTINUE TO PUMP AND SPEND
MET FEDERAL MONEY EVEN AS
INFLATION STARTED TO RISE AT A
VERY ALARMING RATE HE EVEN
PUSHED FOR EVEN MORE SPENDING
EVEN AS WE SPEAK HE STILL WANTS
TO PUMP TRILLIONS OF MORE
DOLLARS INTO THE ECONOMY THIS IS
MADNESS, THIS IS INSANITY AND
THAT'S NOT ALL.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN RESTRICTED
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
IMMEDIATELY PUT ALL THESE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE GAS AND OIL
INDUSTRY.
HE KILLED THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE, BY THE WAY WE BEEN
TAKING IN 900,000 BARRELS OF
CANADIAN OIL A DAY BY NOW THAT
WOULD LOWER THE PRICE OF
EVERYTHING.
AND BY THE WAY IT WAS
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN WHO BANNED
DRILLING ON PUBLIC LANDS BECAUSE
OF COURSE HE IS IN ADHERENT TO
THE RELIGIOUS CLIMATE ALARMIST
COLD THAT NOW RUN HIS ENTIRE
PARTY.
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT HIM HE SAT
BACK AND DID NOTHING AS GAS
PRICES WENT UP, AND UP EXCEPT
MAKE EXCUSES A YEAR AGO TODAY
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN THEY'RE ALL
TELLING US THAT GAS PRICES WOULD
COME DOWN AND THAT INFLATION WAS
TEMPORARY OR THAT IT WAS
TRANSITORY.
THEY WERE ALL LYING OR STUPID OR
THINK ABOUT THE ECONOMY AND THAT
MAGICAL WAY AS BLOOMBERG WAS
REPORTING.
BUT GET THIS AS THE ECONOMY IS
IMPLODING JOE BIDEN IS
RIP-ROARING MAD BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT GIVING JOE BIDEN THE PRESENT
THE CREDIT THAT HE THINKS HE
DESERVES.
OH, WE SHOULD SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE 5,000 INFLATION TAX, THE
$2,000 EXTRA WORK IN A PALE YEAR
FOR GAS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: ON THE
BRINK OF THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LOSE THEIR
JOBS AND THEIR HOMES.
BUT EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY LOSING
HOPE.
NUMBER THOSE LONG LINES YOU'D
SEE ON TELEVISION, PEOPLE LINING
UP IN ALL KINDS OF VEHICLES JUST
TO GET A BOX OF FOOD.
IN THEIR TRUNK.
HOW CAN WE FORGET THAT PEOPLE
WERE HURTING.
AND WHAT DID THIS MAGA CROWD
WANT TO DO?
FORGET IT.
GOD AT THIS OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
TO WAIT IN LINE AN HOUR, AN HOUR
AND A HALF TO GET A BOX OF FOOD
IN THEIR TRUNK IS JUST
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Hannity: YOUR PRESIDENCY IS
UNBELIEVABLY AWFUL WHILE HE'S
WEARING ABOUT GETTING THE CREDIT
HE DESERVES MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO FIELD THEIR
CHILDREN AND I MEAN LITERALLY
AND PAY THEIR RENT AND PAY THEIR
MORTGAGES.
AS WE SPEAK A NATIONWIDE
SHORTAGE OF BABY FORMULA IS NOW
CAUSING PANIC AND WHY BE SO
AMONGST PARENTS AS ONE
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT READS
THAT BABY FORMULA SHORTAGE NOW
LEAVES DESPERATE PARENTS
SEARCHING FOR FOOD.
SOME PARENTS ARE NOW DRIVING
HOURS AT A TIME IN SEARCH OF
SUPPLIES, OTHERS ARE WATERING
DOWN FORMULA OR RATIONING IT
HOPING FOR AN END OF THE
SHORTAGE.
I TALKED TO A FRIEND OF MINE
THEY'RE TRYING TO IMPORTED FROM
EUROPE BUT THEN AGAIN IT GETS
BANNED WERE NOT STOPPING THE
OPIOIDS IN THE FAT NOVEL WILL
STOP THAT BABY FORMULA COMING IN
FROM EUROPE.
THIS IS AN URGENT CRISIS AND THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T CARE THEY HAVE
NO CLUE WHAT TO DO ABOARD
AIR FORCE ONE EARLIER TODAY
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN NEW PRESS
SECRETARY ACTUALLY LAUGHED WHEN
A REPORTER ASKED ABOUT THE
ONGOING SHORTAGE I'M NOT SURE
WHAT'S SO FUNNY HERE I'LL LET
YOU DECIDE.
>> ABOUT THE FORMULA ISSUE?
>> AT THE WHITE HOUSE I DON'T
KNOW [LAUGHS]
I CAN GET YOU A PERSON WHO IS
RUNNING POINTS.
BUT I DON'T HAVE A GOOD IDEA.
>> Hannity: NOT SURE WHAT SO
FORMULA BUT IS NOT BABY FORMULA
WE CAN SOON HAVE A SEVERE
SHORTAGE NATIONWIDE AS AMERICANS
FARMERS, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
HEART AND SOUL OF THIS COUNTRY
THAT FEED ALL OF US WITH THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED TECHNOLOGY
THE SCIENCE INVOLVED IN FARMING
TODAY YES THEY ARE STRUGGLING
WITH ALL THESE RISING ENERGY
COSTS, TRANSPORTATION COSTS,
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES AND BY THE
WAY YOU'RE LOOKING AT THREE
TIMES THE INCREASE IN THE PRICE
OF FERTILIZER THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY AT THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAYS THAT YOU
SHOULD MAY BE COMPOSTING USE
MANURE.
OKAY THEY NEED FERTILIZER LOOK
AT YOUR SCREEN.
THE FOUR MAJOR TYPES OF
FERTILIZER ARE ALL AT RECORD
HIGHS.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS.
YOU LIKE TO EAT, I GO SHOPPING
EVERY WEEK.
I'VE STICKER SHOCK EVERY WEEK,
BUT LOOK AT THESE.
I'LL BUY AS MUCH AS A HUNDRED
AND 15%.
BY THE WAY THE FARMER HAS TO
MAKE A LIVING IF THE RAISE RAISE
THEIR PRICES ON EVERYTHING SO
THEY CAN KEEP THEIR FARMS GOING.
AND FEAR NOT BECAUSE TODAY JOE
WE ACTUALLY VISITED A FARM ONCE
AGAIN REMINDED EVERYONE THAT HIS
HOME STATE OF DELAWARE HAS A LOT
OF FARMS TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: THINGS
THAT I WANT TO PUT THE REST IS
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN IN A FARM?
I REMIND THEM THAT NOBODY KNOWS.
I COME FROM THE STATE OF
DELAWARE I REPRESENTED DELAWARE
FOR 36 YEARS IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
BEFORE HE BECAME VICE PRESIDENT
SINGLE LARGEST INDUSTRY IN
DELAWARE DELAWARE PENINSULA.
AS A $4 BILLION INDUSTRY.
A $4 BILLION IN WHOLE PENINSULA.
WE HAVE MORE CHICKENS THAN
AMERICANS.
MORE BROILERS.
>> Hannity: MAY BE IT'S MORE
PROGRESS HE WASN'T BRAGGING THAT
HIS STATE WAS A SLAVE STATE AS
HE ONCE SAID.
OF COURSE HE'S NEVER WORKED AS A
FARMER THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES
HE HASN'T HELD IN A JOB OUTSIDE